est-ce que c'est normal la symétrie de
la poitrine bon j'imagine qu'on parle
des seins pas des pecs et ben très
clairement oui c'est normal enfin je
sais pas ce que tu entends par normal
mais en tout cas c'est très très très
répondu avoir un sein plus gros que
l'autre c'est vrai chez la majorité des
gens si on veut être un peu tatillon je
pense même qu'on peut dire que personne
n'a une poitrine parfaitement symétrique
juste des fois la différence elle est
tellement minime que ça se voit pas à
l'œil nu mais elle existe quand même par
contre oui des fois ça se voit et quand
je parle de différence bah ça peut être
la taille mais ça peut aussi être la
forme le mamelon et cetera et cetera
donc c'est normal mais si ça te
travaille il y a deux questions à se
poser la première c'est est-ce que ça me
dérange vraiment auquel cas c'est bien
d'aller en parler avec quelqu'un et si
au bout du compte ça continue à être
gênant bah c'est possible de se faire
opérer c'est pas obligé mais c'est
possible et l'autre question c'est
est-ce que ça a toujours été comme ça
oou est-ce que c'est apparu un peu d'un
coup et là si c'est oui il faut aller
chez le médecin pour comprendre pourquoi